Well what if we share a different destiny
a little more scorched earth chakra dog
blood and bone
Welcome back everyone this is
going to be my full video for the boys season
episodes one through three there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs for marvel and dc
everyone better hide their milk if you're brand
new to the channel i will be doing videos for
all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them all careful for spoilers from episodes
1 to 3 if you haven't seen them yet but i'll
start at the beginning in episode 1 and we'll
work our way through shot by shot talking about
easter eggs and moments as we go along so i'll
try to keep this video from turning into like
an hour long video because there's so much to
talk about and they are really long episodes they
cover a bunch of brand new stuff and introduce a
bunch of new characters like soldier boy jensen
ackles for instance but the title of episode 1
is payback that's meant to be a reference to the
payback team in the comics that's meant to be an
avengers marvel reference payback as in revenge or
the revengers if you want to make jokes about that
in the comics stormfront was the leader of that
team they're meant to be like the second backup
team to the seven on the show they're saying the
payback was the team that soldier boy led during
the 80s before he was put on ice effectively the
way they're using him on the tv show is that he's
meant to be like the prototype for homelander so
he's a little bit different from the comic book
version there are a couple different versions in
the comics and they kind of combined both of those
to form jensen ackle's character vought wound
up using him as a prototype for what eventually
became the homelander character like they created
him in a test tube as he says i don't even know
what my own birthday is there's this whole subplot
with him refining the compound v formula over time
to present day when he develops that temporary
version of the formula which is actually a really
big deal with butcher getting powers which
is all part of this larger ploy that he's
been engineering to try and get superheroes in the
military and just become a more profitable company
that gets into more of the white house plot don't
worry i'll talk about that because that's like a
subplot that's running across all these different
story lines through the first couple of episodes
it all comes back around to this four-dimensional
chess game that stan edgar has been playing all
the way since the flashbacks the actual opening
scene of episode one is that hilarious seven movie
that they were shooting all of last season dawn
of the seven is meant to be a big justice league
snyder cut easter egg but the title is meant to be
a reference to batman v superman dawn of justice
the way they use the movie and the jokes they make
are meant to be both marvel avengers end game and
justice league snyder cup parodies bigger surprise
they recat charlize the ron as the stormfront
character and just re-shot all of her scenes they
also make a bit of a star wars rogue one joke too
when they were making the rogue one movie the
original director gareth edwards kind of got
pushed aside and brought in tony gilroy to
rewrite and re-shoot a ton of it they make
all these jokes about release the board cut
released the snyder cut obviously even zack
snyder got in on the jokes tweeting about it like
haha yeah i'm so happy to see your vision realized
when they all team up to fight stormfront they
also make an avengers endgame portals joke like
when all the other heroes of the seven show up the
ironic thing with having charlize theron play this
villain stormfront character obviously is that
we just saw her and doctor strange too in the
post credit scene she's not going to be clia
inside the mcu i did a whole bunch of videos
about that so i'll post them in the description
below because that's meant to be a big secret wars
teaser obviously very different from what's going
on during the universe of the boys but you also
notice in the background of this scene there's
this very prominent ad ad placement for turbo rush
which is a train soft drink and it's just showing
you how vought has cleverly manipulated the movie
after the big stormfront incident to capitalize
on all the pr and earn even more money there's
this whole subplot throughout the episode that
just kind of shows you that everything that vod
does is all about making money they're meant to
be this pharmaceutical company as stan edgar says
they don't really care about superheroes it's all
just about earning more money the only difference
now in present day is that stan edgar wants to
transition them to become more of a pharmaceutical
and more of a defense contractor and just forget
about all the superhero in the merchandising stuff
but like there's all these jokes about the tv
networks they own all the branded entertainment
all the ad placements that they put within all
of their media it's meant to seem like they have
their tendrils in everything they're controlling
everything that you see everything that you hear
and now everything that you believe because the
stan edgar eventually tells starlight real power
is all about influencing people it's not about
actually having real superpowers then they confirm
pretty much all of our theories about what's going
on with victoria newman she is working with stan
edgar although it goes way deeper than i thought
in the past the full backstory on her character
is that we find out that vought has this facility
called red river where they send all their failed
superheroes so like they give compound v to
a bunch of babies hoping that they'll have
powers that they can profit off of but sometimes
the children's powers manifest before they learn
how to control them and they accidentally kill
their parents also sometimes they don't know what
their powers are or they have really weird powers
that they can't control and the parents abandoned
them and victoria newman was one of these kids
that accidentally wound up killing her parents
when she was a child and was sent to the facility
but eventually stan edgar saw that there was
potential in her and kind of adopted her and she
became his surrogate daughter eventually using her
as sort of his ploy on the other side of things
in the government to try and get a foothold in the
actual us government it's all about stan edgar's
plan to basically control all different aspects
of the game he wants real power and what that
means and this kind of dovetails with the comic
book plot is being able to control the white house
there's also the supernatural easter eggs of this
too there's a lot of supernatural stuff going on
in this show with a bunch of different characters
everyone knows about jim beaver's robert singer
character from the government he was on during
season two robert singer was one of the producers
of supernatural that's why they use that name for
this character because the showrunner of
the boys the creator of the boys tv show
is the original creator of the supernatural tv
show that's the connection back to jensen ackles
as well too and jeffrey dean morgan who is on
that show is gonna cameo during season four
but boston edgar is revealing this grand plan
about getting superheroes in the military
he's kind of soft revealing his plan to control
public policy in the white house and the entire
government when he reveals that he's also funding
robert singer's presidential campaign oh people
love a cowboy in the white house also revealing
that he kind of controls congress because of
victoria newman because like right after he says
oh i can grease the wheels in congress they cut
straight to victoria newman also revealing what's
going on with this new department of superheroes
working within the cia is all stan edgar's
four-dimensional chess game controlling every
aspect of the game what he's trying to do with
victoria newman's department is basically show
her being successful in the public eye to make
her more popular making it easier for her to gain
more power in congress and like they have that
really big famous scene don't worry i'll get to
that there's so much we could say about that stan
edgar is basically having them go after bottom
feeder superheroes that he doesn't care about
anymore or who he can't profit off of because the
minute that their ant-man parody character winds
up becoming profitable again he tells them to go
find another superhero like oh we can't arrest him
because vat just said he got a merchandising deal
but the whole reason he's doing this trying to
turn the company into more of a defense contractor
a true pharmaceutical company is because literally
is just more profitable he wants to sell the
military doses of this new version of compound fee
2 million dollars of pop which essentially works
out to 600 million dollars per squad and there are
many squads in the military so even just having a
month-long campaign vought is going to be earning
many many billions of dollars he's not lying when
he's telling robert singer's character that this
business of being in superheroes is just way too
much trouble than it's worth so when he says in
the next couple of years he says that he does not
plan to be in the superhero game that's basically
him foreshadowing the end of the series like in
a couple years when we get to like season four
season five whatever their final season winds up
being that's gonna be the end quote unquote of
everything that also dovetails with this whole
homelander plot when he goes to butcher and they
talk about getting all biblical like don't you
want to go all scorched dirt on this like just you
versus me that's basically what homelander sees as
the boys end game so with stan edgar planning on
phasing out superheroes just in general wanting to
get rid of them and homelander wanted to just
completely lose it on the rest of the world
you see this all culminating in the next couple
of years battle royale for the planet of the boys
we gotta talk about that thanos scene though
obviously it wasn't exactly like the thanos but
it basically is a faintest scene the character
that frenchie and kimiko go after is meant to
be an ant-man parody they call him termite on the
show he winds up killing his partner accidentally
because he sneezes but in the thanos way all the
funny scenes of him fighting kimiko and frenchie
is just meant to show you how much trouble ant-man
could cause how powerful he could be if he really
went off the chain i'm sure if you really tried
you could also probably take out ant-man with a
giant bag of coke too throughout all the episodes
there are a billion different marvel and dc parody
characters that they name off but like in episode
one when they talk about the different ones that
they're going after there's cold snap which
i think is meant to be a captain cold parody
stacker and air burst i think the air burst is
meant to be another tornado twins easter egg
but there is a pair of twins on the payback team
back in the 80s i think that they're actually
meant to be the direct tornado twins easter
egg don't worry i'll talk about the payback
team in a second they don't really get into
their backstory till you get to episode three
but you see early on with this whole temporary
compound v formula plot that they're trying to
set up a parallel between butcher and homelanders
arc both of them are totally nuts in the comics
butcher is supposed to be as terrible as
homelanders just in a completely different
direction he goes off the rails just the same
way that home later also goes off the rails
the tv show is trying to be a little bit more
subtle about it but that's the whole struggle with
him trying to decide whether or not to take the
compound v which he eventually does i love the way
that he also hallucinates talking to himself as a
young person to homelander to huey when he thinks
about taking it for the first time he doesn't
want to turn into someone as bad as homelander
but he's being pushed in that direction like
towards the end of episode three they literally
say we can't do things above board anymore we
have to be just as terrible as the other guys
in the comic book they do way crazier stuff so if
you want like the full dose of craziness just read
the comic they reveal that starlight and huey are
still in a relationship they're living together
but there's this whole subplot with her becoming
co-captain of the seven and kind of having to sit
within the belly of the beast also slowly losing
it in the same way that homelander is slowly
losing it there's a big flashback during episode
three where they show you her as a child being
forced to do all these pageants for vaude you see
her clench her fist to try and suppress her rage
she also does that in present day after she's
forced to stay within the seven and put up with
all this craziness like she has to pretend to
be homelanders girlfriend now in the public
they also bring back huey's dad played by simon
pegg the big easter egg here is that originally
the creator of the boys comic book designed huey
to look like simon pegg and originally he was
gonna play huey if they had made the boys tv show
back in the early 2000s but because he got too old
he just wound up playing his dad but they just did
a boys diabolical animated short series and during
one of those episodes they actually had simon pegg
playing a version of huey from the comics and it
was more accurate to the comic books the brand
new super sonic character they introduced used
to be starlight's boyfriend when they were on the
teenage kicks which is like their version of the
teen titans they have this big reality show called
american superhero which they're using to find the
next member of the seven but really i mean it's
just vought trying to earn more money the other
heroes that were competing on the team were meant
to be moon shadow which i think is meant to be
a moon dragon parody in silver kinkade which i
believe is meant to be a silver sable reference
if you're a big fan of reality tv they also
spend a lot of time making fun of different
aspects of reality tv and it's all true probably
one of the bigger wtf's especially early on though
is the reveal that stormfront's still alive the
showrunner said that she was still supposed to
be alive but didn't reveal exactly how they were
going to use her they reveal she's being kept in
homelanders apartment in the tower of the seven
but she's basically an invalid like she's full
anakin skywalker burnt toast she has the one
working hand but essentially it's a living hell
for her they make a joke about her still giving
hand jobs to homelander and it's just completely
not working because she's still going full nazi
on him and obviously the revealed that stormfront
killed herself rather than surviving in that
state like it became a living nightmare for her
when ashley makes the joke about stormfront
million dollar babying herself during that
movie the protagonist bites out her own tongue
attempting to bleed to death that's how stormfront
was able to kill herself they said that this whole
running storyline with soldier boy's character
most of it is meant to be a misdirect like
maeve kind of tips him off like oh they told
this story about him dying in a nuclear meltdown
in the mid-80s but that's all a lie soldier boy
obviously jensen ackle's character we've seen
him in the trailer we know he's coming back in
present day but it sounds like we don't see him in
present day till at least episode 4 or episode 5.
they changed him a little bit from the comics
but essentially soulja boy was meant to be the
americans first version of a superhero whereas
stormfront was the first version of the nazi's
superhero soulja boy is meant to be a big captain
america parody his backstory is pretty much the
same as captain america's he's meant to be
the douchiest version of captain america you
could possibly imagine you get that kind of vibe
when he's talking to mallory in the flashbacks
when they explain mallory's history with him in
the iran contra incident that is them trying to do
a version of the comics just using a different war
because everything happening is happening later in
the timeline that it was in the comics you see
the old version of soldier boy during world war
ii era looks like then the young version of stan
edgar makes it sound like soulja boy was also
present for the korean war but for some
reason wasn't involved in the vietnam war
because when the young version of stan edgar is
talking to malory in the mid-80s he says that it's
been almost 30 years since they've had a superhero
inside the military they have a parody of the wasp
they have a professor x parody who's a telepath
they have a tornado twins parody like i said
gunpowder is more of a judge dread parody but the
way they're using him is more of a bucky parody
because he's the sidekick of soldier boy their
version of lori holden is playing crimson countess
she's meant to be a scarlet witch parody obviously
kind of funny after seeing doctor strange 2 with
that version of scarlet witch in the mcu and
they reveal a whole bunch about black noir's
backstory apparently he just used to be totally
normal i think they want to juxtapose his tragic
backstory with a train's backstory like they want
to show what could potentially happen to a train
if he stays with the seven the same way that black
noir has stayed with the seven this should also
show you that the black noir on the tv show isn't
meant to be like the comic book version so they're
probably not gonna have the same type of ending
for that character with the ending for homelander
that the comics did i think when we talk about
what ultimately happens to homelander it's all
about what's going on with ryan's character he is
meant to be the homelander deterrent but there's
this whole subplot with what really happened
to soldier boy during that incident and even
mallory has the wool pulled over her eyes and she
believes that he's dead which obviously isn't true
because we've seen him in the trailer but they
believe there's some secret weapon that killed
soldier boy that the russians somehow have access
to when really i think it's all about some crazy
twist behind soldier boy's powers and stan edgar
really trying to put him on ice and just use him
as research material to try and create a better
superhero which winds up culminating in homelander
so this whole subplot with them thinking that
there's a weapon that they're going to find is
probably going to lead to actual soldier boy
like wait a minute what are you doing here
love all the funny moments with them going around
to the different payback members and just things
going completely off the rails trying to get more
information about it too butcher had made the
decision to try the compound v before he learned
about the truth of victoria newman though even
though it seemed like that pushed him over the
edge lego that's it gloves are off now probably
one of the most messed up moments though is when
homelander loses it on the girl that he's supposed
to be saving like oh maybe you should jump no
seriously you should definitely jump right now
that happens during episode 2 the title of that
episode is the man in the sky which is a reference
to homelander because he flies he is the man in
the sky but it's also a reference to god like
the big guy up there in homelanders whole speech
about how people are essentially killing their god
and now there is no god he is the only man in the
sky so everyone should start bowing to him that's
also meant to connect with the conversation he
has with starlight challenging her to actually
release the video of the plane because he doesn't
care anymore either way he's thirsty for the love
and attention of the entire world but he's just
fine in having everyone fear him meaning that he
doesn't care about anything anymore so they have
no leverage anymore all bringing it back around
to that conversation that he has with butcher
in episode one about his scorched earth policy
like literally scorching the earth because he
talks about destroying all these big population
centers remember that's like end game for the boys
show in a couple seasons that is unless ryan is
eventually able to challenge and stop him when
we start learning more about the truth of what
really happened with the payback team and soldier
boy in the past we learned that soldier boy all
those superheroes are incompetent just like the
ones in present-day cause just as much collateral
damage bot tries to cover it up just the same we
learned that during that period in the 80s soldier
boy wound up killing mother's milk's family and
it just drove him crazy this whole time trying to
figure out what actually happened and how to get
back at them you think that butcher is hardcore
i cannot wait to see what mother's milk tries to
do to soldier boy but they end episode 3 with this
huge reveal that homelander now just completely
lost it has brought deep back to the seven there's
so many messed up moments with that character
but they bring him back onto the seven for the
same reason why homelander tries to announce to
the public that he's now in a relationship with
starlight because it's all a big ratings ploy and
it places that same base that loved him losing
his mind on live television and if it wasn't clear
during that celebratory dinner where he basically
forces him to eat his friends like he has him eat
all this shellfish like please give me some bread
don't make me eat my friends homelander forces
the deep to eat his friend timothy the octopus
who he was getting it on with while he was doing
it with his wife like as messed up as that scene
was with him in the octopus and his wife he also
has to eat that octopus alive and wally's doing
it he basically narrates everything the octopus
is saying as it's in the process of dying like oh
my god he has a wife and family that he's caring
about he's begging for his life he's praying now
as he crunches down on him the boys is one of
those tv shows where like each moment is more
messed up than the last and you think that they
can't top themselves but somehow it gets even
crazier and we're only at episode 3 right now
and speaking of messed up things that the boys
is getting ready to do the global wellness retreat
in malibu the victoria newman talks about is the
boy's tv show version of the herogasm vot lies
to the public telling him that it's this learning
experience that superheroes go to every year but
really it's meant to be like the most debaucherous
version of superhero spring break that you've ever
seen but there are a billion things that happen in
these first couple of episodes i didn't include
everything in this video just because i didn't
want it to turn into like an hour long video so
if there's anything that i didn't talk about that
you have questions about just write it below in
the comments and we'll cover it in the comments
my full video for the boys season 3 episode 4 will
post next week on friday it'll be a friday show
my full obi-wan kenobi episode 4 video will also
post next week and marvel also has a brand new
weekly series that's starting next week so we'll
be eating really good make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for my full obi-wan kenobi
episode 3 video in easter eggs and click here
for my brand new obi-wan kenobi episode 4 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!